et si je vous disais que votre famille a
été assassinée
sans aucune raison
[Musique]
et maintenant posez-vous cette question
que feriez-vous
non je veux pouvoir me venger je le
mérite
qui sont tous ces gens
les Justiciers juifs
il s'appelle même Nakam
le mot biblique pour la vengeance il ne
tue pas que des criminels de guerre
il tue aussi des civils allemands
ils prévoient quelque chose de gros un
Nuremberg
je te fais confiance
on ira plus jamais comme des moutons à
la battoir
plus jamais
[Musique]
le plan est plus important que nous tous
leur vengeance prévoit de faire
d'énormes dégâts
c'est de la folie mais pour eux c'est la
justice
on doit arrêter ces personnes
on doit répondre le poison ici tu penses
vraiment qu'on peut tuer des millions de
personnes et en sortir vivant
[Musique]
mais pour nous c'est toute la nation
allemande qui doit être jugée tous les
Allemands sont coupables
nous sommes sur le point de changer le
cours de l'histoire
plus jamais
pour un
si des millions pour 6 millions